hello everybody my name is markiplier
and today is my birthday
hooray I'm 28 years old so with that
being said I thought that I would take a
little walk down memory lane and take a
look at my old channel literally this is
my old channel I talk about this a lot
but I never go here you can still find
it if you go to youtube.com slash user
slash markiplier instead of youtube.com
slash markiplier but this is my old
channel and I wanted to take you behind
the scenes and actually show you some
videos that have never seen the light of
day again
since I restarted also um I go oh my god
they've got archives of it back in April
25th oh there it is oh my God look at
that oh it was so nice oh it was so well
designed I miss the old style
he was so good the information was like
all there on the feed I aim to upload
roughly four to five videos per day
depending on how productive I feel or
excited I am without a game stick around
and enjoy the show
this channel got banned for [ __ ]
reasons obviously it was because YouTube
said that I was breaking their
monetization policy but I wasn't even
monetizing the videos so how could I
have done that either way this channel
is gone and here are the videos that are
immortalized in time and I want you guys
to look at this because this was over
five years ago I actually set these
videos to private and so the likes and
the number of views all are frozen in
time and as you can see see I wasn't
lying they're not monetized because I
didn't monetize my video that was your
tube being up all good [ __ ] what we
have here is we have everything that I
did in the few months that I did it on
this channel this first channel here and
you can see and what I want to show you
guys for those that are starting out I
want to show you guys what it was like
to be back in these early stages before
I even start
this one actually is the only video on
my channel or one of the few that are
actually public this video is when
everything changed because this video
got shared to Reddit
and then got spanned on and pushed
farther and farther and then somehow got
uploaded like crazy and suddenly I found
myself in the unique position of having
not only new subscribers not a lot mind
you not a lot I don't want you guys to
think that I had just doodles and
rulings of subscribers not a lot three
weeks after that went viral I still only
at 9:28 and that's where this started
that's the work that it took I didn't
care what other people were getting I
cared about what I was getting right
then and there the progress that I was
making the slow March and then
especially when you have to compare I
believe this had a hundred thousand
views when it first went viral and then
comparing that and feeling the
difference when you make these Let's
Plays and they get hundreds of views
compared to a hundred thousand that can
be really impactful but I didn't let it
slow me down not once and I guess
there's a message to you up-and-coming
youtubers here like it starts slow it
really does and the benefit here is like
I'm getting hundreds of views and for
some people that's a lot of views this
is the march of progress and and in
these Let's Plays these are completely
uncut Let's Plays because I just assume
that's what it was who needs their face
punched god this is such good titles
return of the whale call fear the chair
the terror begins Oh in the hundredth
video monologue my viewers is that still
on my channel like hang on let me
actually look that up yeah it's here
thank you guys so much for helping me
get to this point like it's you guys if
you guys going out sharing my videos
liking my videos favoriting my videos
of subscribing liking it's you guys
doing this stuff commenting as well that
just helps me get more attention and
build up and like this is something that
I want to do full-time I would love to
be able to do this for a living like
maybe with your guys's help someday I
can get to that point and like I love
playing video games and I love
commentating on video games I love
acting like a stupid idiot sometimes
just to make you guys laugh I love
screaming like a little girl just to
make you guys laugh so thank you guys
thank you so much I can't fit I can't
say thank you enough and but I'll stop
saying thank you because I said it way
too much
all right so just um well a couple thank
you guys so much for watching oh that's
so cool this video you can actually find
if you want to listen to that monologue
and I would love to listen to it now
when I I don't want this video just be
all about listening like me talk both
here in the future and then in the past
so I'm gonna leave that to itself you
guys can check that out that it
currently on this channel but let's get
back to the old one because there's more
here that I want to see like I joined
this to be a quick look at this um but
there's something here else that I
wanted to show you ah here it is one
month of doing Let's Plays what does
that mean I have not seen this video
since I posted it I have no idea what
I'm going to say here and also you'll
see how baby I am but it's still here
hello everybody and welcome to buy one
month stated the channel video I just
wanted to take a moment to tell you how
the channels been doing give you some
statistics and let you know where I want
to take this channel in the future as of
this video I have one thousand three
hundred and fifty six subscribers and
one hundred ninety nine thousand four
hundred and sixty-two views that's in
exactly one month one month ago
from today I uploaded my first video
that is amazing I've received 125
dislikes 6615 likes that's good if I
also received 2222 comments 157 shares
and my videos have been favorited 1465
time boy now obviously my highest viewed
video is the amnesia reaction
compilation because that video alone
netted me three hundred and seventy two
subscribers throughout the entirety of
my channels that was it that's all I got
from that I thought I got more than that
it leaves like 900 oh my god I only got
300 of them geez I don't understand why
I'm talking about I know it's because my
life was so boring I'm gonna keep
pumping my life was so boring I had no
idea what else to talk about I just had
statistics because when you're a
youtuber I didn't read any manuals on
how to be a youtuber I just was like I
should update them on my life I mean
that was my mindset I think at the time
if I remember correctly in this dopey
face guy but that was my mindset yeah I
was like hey this is our channel is our
channel you guys should know I guess
excessive facecam got added people
really really like seeing me scream like
a little girl so I'm gonna leave that in
for all beforehand not so much with not
more games because I don't think you
guys want to see me picking my nose
while I shoot bad guys that's the four
games for your 3d screen what kind
narcissistic [ __ ] and I'm laughing
at my joke that I made five years ago I
wanted honestly I want to be the best
- commentator that I can I feel that
I've been inspired to work harder and
crew myself to try to provide better
entertainment with you guys like I'm
doing this for you guys because I love
to entertain
I want and anyone I don't just want to
be a good entertainer I want to be the
best entertainer I could be I'm not
saying that I'm going to be the best in
the world but I want to take this
channel as far as I can and the only way
that I can do that is with you guys is
help be liking and favoriting only goes
so far the real way to grow a channel is
for you guys to share my videos and this
is Professor probably gonna be the only
time that I'm really going to ask you
guys see see see I'm not calling anybody
out because I'm still doing it I'm like
hey can you hear chairs were a little
low this month I'm going to make a
teacher
it just says shares were a little low
this month can you can you give me a
share
hashtag share a markiplier he needs it
bad but no see I'm not gay I'm not
guiltless I do need your help to grow I
want to be one of the biggest YouTube
gaming channels available like as big as
all the top hey John how long ago that
point and the only way to do that is if
you guys are showing your friends my
videos but I'm not even gonna go down
luck but that gave me I think it got me
because I made it
like who would have put money if anyone
was to put money on a doof like this
making it pivot kick oh no crying hear
that [ __ ] [ __ ] and the reason like
the reason I'm showing you guys this the
reason I'm showing you what this is all
about the reason I go into the past is
to show you guys anybody can do it
look at this doof look at him look at
this dude look at this dude
look at this dude it's not magic it's
not magic it's just hard work it's hard
work and a desire to improve yourself
I'm not eloquent here I'm not I'm not
eloquent I'm not well-spoken I'm not
exercised in the vocal region here and
yet I just had a passion to do it and I
did it I can't but be proud of that
you know if I could tell younger me he's
happened it's really simple there's only
been 157 chairs
oh here I go oh no but the easiest way
to do if half of the people that saw
this video um posted one of my reactions
compilations on their Facebook page or
timeline if you have Facebook or Twitter
then now more than double the amount of
shares that I've had in a month uh and
that would exponentially increase my
buzz the one thing that I ask of you
guys is if you can if you don't have to
if you have the time or if you have a
Facebook just pick out one of your
favorite reaction compilation mind
whichever one that you like the most and
just post it on your Facebook wall
that's it that's all you have to do you
don't have to send it to friends you
know you just post it on your own and
that will dramatically
exponentially increasing slow dragon so
that that's all that's what I mean anime
but all in all I can't believe how much
you guys have made my channel what it is
so far I mean getting 1356 subscribers
in a month is almost unreal for a gaming
channel it's it's nothing short of
amazing
even is incredible and I can only thank
you so much and I know that with your
help I'm gonna move forward and I'm
gonna be the biggest YouTube gaming
commentary that I can and hopefully
that's right up there with none if you
believe in me I'm going to stick with it
I'm not going to quit I'm never gonna
quit I'm going to keep going and a year
from now on April 5th of 2013 if the
world is still here if it hasn't all
exploded in April 5th of 2015 I'll make
another hump and we'll see where we are
there and with your help
hopefully my subscriber count will be in
the 5 maybe even more can do the one
favor of sharing my videos and reaching
out to your friends and if you want to
do more that's great thank you but I'm
not going to ask
than just sharing one of my reaction
compilations on your Facebook wall or
Twitter and thank you guys I just can't
do anything else but thank you guys what
what's amazing about that and what's
amazing it the message that I'm trying
to send off to you guys each day I'm
still here I didn't lie cuz I didn't lie
to myself I didn't lie to you guys I
didn't lie to you because we're all here
as much as it may feel like you're a
passive viewer you're on board in this
community we are all here together and
whether you want to be passive or not
that's fine but those of you who have
been here since the beginning and I know
I know there's some people that have
been here since the very beginning
because I met people at VidCon that have
been watching since five years ago
people sometimes that I can even
remember people that come to comic-con
every year the person that I met at
comic-con the very first year still
meets me every year and even if you
watch through my videos in the timeline
if you've been here with me you've seen
every emotion of me either like
criticizing myself or lamenting the fact
that I can't speak to everybody and I've
come to terms with that and I've
realized things and I've learned things
over time and I'm hard on myself because
I don't give up
I'm hard on myself because I want to be
better but even now I want to be better
I want to be the best I don't feel like
I'm there I don't feel like I'm there
I'm 28 now I was 22 in that video I want
to be better every day I want to be
better I just do I can't stop trying I
can't stop working I can't stop pushing
myself to be better and reach farther
than I ever have because what I want is
still the same as I wanted back
and I want to be here for you I want to
be here with you I want to go on this
journey and see where it and I look back
at their stuff and I remember barber
yeah I remember Boop super juice is this
even on my channel currently hello you
look blue did it ideal haha woo super
cute
woo oh yeah oh that's classic markiplier
right there do you want to know how I
got four to six videos every day I mean
[ __ ] like and you want to know what not
a single [ __ ] dislike not a one not
one dislike [ __ ] yeah [ __ ] yeah okay
even my tag is one have I done and and
what's most amazing to me after because
I felt bad when I remember I felt bad
when I asked you know people to share
because I was like oh I don't know if
people are gonna see it I was people are
gonna thank think that I'm just whoring
myself out and but I mean the response
it's an honest response it's an honest
request and the response was honest it
really was the response was honest and
it worked and I was so grateful that
people did and even today I'm grateful
that you do I'm grateful that you guys
share my videos I'm grateful that you
guys watch I'm never not grateful and I
want to show that by continuing to
improve myself you know I I also
appreciate the people that are like you
don't need to be so hard on yourself but
to be perfectly honest I do
I gotta that's who I am I'm improving
myself all the time because I reach
higher every day every day the hustle is
a mad hustle it dick flow everywhere and
even though like I don't do this anymore
I don't ask people because like I miss
and there's a video on my channel that
exists I believe it's ah this is this
was a ripeness of fears watch to the end
very important message just an honest
true not clickbait at all I was goofin
with it and you know I'll being why
would be mcgoofy self but then you know
at the end was this really heartfelt
trip down memory lane and I got really
really really really emotional about
that because I remember and the lesson
to be learned there isn't that it's
wrong to want more but it's wrong to
forget how you got there
you can you can ask for help and I can
ask you guys to help me spread my videos
to help share a cool experience with
your friends it's not wrong of me to ask
it's not wrong of me to want to be where
I am today and want to be where I could
be in the future but it's wrong to
forget how you got there and that was an
important lesson that I learned playing
that game if I didn't learn that lesson
I wouldn't be where I am today if I
didn't hold myself accountable for the
mistakes of my past and so if this video
is anything like on my birthday if I had
anything to ask for you guys from you
guys on my birthday it is that you guys
remember why you're doing that thing you
want to do without the why of it there's
no point in you getting success you got
to remember the nitty-gritty of it you
got to remember every day you got to
look back yourself and not look at
others and judge yourself by the
standards of which do not matter what
matter are these moments and the more
beautiful moment of this is the one
video that's on the front page of this
and and in this video I'm not going to
watch go through this whole video it's
like you guys have probably seen it or
you can see it for yourself in this
video like I asked again a heartfelt
true request
explaining what happened explaining that
my channel can't be monetized because my
adsense account got banned and
explaining honestly and truly that I
didn't want to give up I wasn't gonna
quit come on [ __ ] tears huh I wasn't
gonna quit and then I wanted to keep
going that's what it was all about and
then you guys responded you guys
responded I'm really tried I want to cry
in this one [ __ ] uh but you guys
responded and I reapplied it every
single one of my videos when I ask
people to go to my new channel and
please subscribe and like and favorite
REE favorite we like we share like I
asked these things and like it was an
unrestricted
and you guys said yes it was so
beautiful and like to this day when I do
charity livestreams and I ask an honest
ask I just ask you guys please to give
what you can't and you do you do hmm you
do you really really do that's what's so
beautiful about it you make me have so
much hope for this because god it was so
long ago and I almost quit I almost quit
there but then I was like after my
conversations with my friends and I came
back and I thought about it was like one
day later I was like well [ __ ] it here
we go I'm gonna re-up load everything on
my shitty mom's internet and that was it
and that's all work knew ah [ __ ] you
great god is great and you got and oh
well now that I'm 28 you know what's
changed
not a thing that's why I'm so hard on
myself that's why I'm so happy that's
why I'm so unimaginably ecstatic to make
videos oh I love this this honesty this
truth like this this on paralleled
honesty and that's what I want and if I
had anything to ask of you guys on my
birthday it would be to go back and find
your favorite video your number-one
favorite video of mine the one that made
you subscribe or the one that you loved
the most and just share it like I don't
even it's not even for growing my
channel because my channel is [ __ ]
huge like that's not what's important
what's important is remembering the why
of it why you guys subscribe to this
channel why you guys feel any sort of
emotion when you watch my videos and why
you care I want to know why you care I
want to know what made that first clock
pop into your head I want to know that
honestly and truly I want to know that
so please take the time go back in my
channel look through and just try to
find that one video that really
resonated with it could be a vlog it
could be a gameplay it could be a whole
series it could be a compilation it
could be one of the stupid videos like
whatever it is I want to know what it is
I just do so with that I've run this
video way too long I I know I cut it
down a bit but I this this video was
it's one of those things that's
important to me this stream of
consciousness in this look back into the
world that exists in this box and just
seeing like what it all mean hey thank
you everybody so much for watching thank
you for being with me for so long and
for those of you who are new to the
channel welcome on board if you're new
to the channel and you haven't dug
there's there there's 3,700 videos in
there go fine look at one of the other
videos that someone else has shared and
look at that one and see why ask
why tell why that video is important
even then it'll be a cool day of
remember remembering what it's all -
thank you everybody so much for watching
it and as always I will see you in the
next video bye bye
[Music]